this next story is so insane that it is almost
unbelievable and difficult to even explain.
I'm going to try. Donald Trump concocted a
plan to ambush the parents of a grieving child
with the woman who killed their child in a
traffic accident. Last week, I told you the
story about the wife of an American diplomat.
Her name is Anne [inaudible]. She was in the
United Kingdom with her husband. Her husband
was stationed there. She ran over and killed
the British teenager, 19 year old named Harry
Dunn, who was riding a motorcycle because
she rode. She drove on the wrong side of the
street. Donald Trump had a very strange reaction
last week where we discussed it, where Trump
said it happens. And he said, I won't say
it hasn't happened to me, I guess referring
to driving on the wrong side of the road in
England, I don't really know what he meant.
I also didn't think Donald Trump drove, but
in any case, it's open to interpretation what
Trump meant by that.
But the parents of the deceased 19 year old
have been lobbying Donald Trump to send SSA
coolest back to the United Kingdom to face
justice. Now, we don't know if what she did
would have her criminally liable or responsible,
uh, jail time. We don't know anything about
that. What we do know is she fled the United
Kingdom when this all went down claiming questionable
diplomatic immunity because her husband was
not actually registered as a diplomat according
to at least one lawyer. So the Dunn family
comes to the United States, uh, not necessarily
expecting to meet with Trump, uh, based on
the reports I've seen. But suddenly they receive
an invitation from the white house marked
urgent to come and visit with Donald Trump.
In the white house on Tuesday night less than
48 hours ago and Donald Trump has since admitted
that he actually sprung on the family that
Hey, the killer and Sikuliaq [inaudible] is
right over in the next room over. How about
I bring her in? Here's Donald Trump explaining
it in the bizarre way that only Donald Trump
can. Once again talking about it happens and
it also sounds like Trump thinks they drive
on the left side of the road in all of Europe,
which is of course not true, but a minor detail.
Just another one of the many details Trump
doesn't understand.
I'm meeting with the family was really a,
it was beautiful in a certain way. They did
not want to meet with the person in question,
but we had a very good meeting. They're very
nice people. It was very sad to be honest.
She lost and they lost their son. I believe
it was going down the wrong way because that
happens in Europe. You go to Europe and the
roads are opposite and it's very tough. If
you're from the United States, you do make
that, that decision to make a right turn where
you're supposed to make a left turn. The roads
are opposite. And she said that's what happened.
That happens to a lot of people by the way.
But she said that's what happened. She was
in the room right out there. We met right
here and these, this area. And I offered to
bring the person in question and, and they
weren't ready for it, but I did offer, I spoke
with, uh, Boris. He asked me if I do that.
And I did it.
Of course, the parents were instantly traumatized
by this incredibly crass and shortsighted
and totally ignorant idea. They said, no,
we don't want to meet the person who ran over
and killed our son. And Trump has since acknowledged
that the parents weren't ready to meet the
woman who ran over and killed their son. And
now as they see it is evading justice but
happened to be sitting in the next room over.
Donald Trump had the idea, almost like he's
a game show host, which is actually a term
we've used before to describe his presidency,
that he'd convinced the parents that this
is a good idea to have this meeting and that
then he would sweep in and so coolest from
the next room over in front of a spray of
photographers. And it would be some kind of
a media event of some sort. I have a surprise
for you behind door number three.
Can you guess who it is? Can you guess something
very, very wrong with this man? And there's
actually something even more stunning. Uh,
the parents say Harry Dunn's parents say that
up until the moment when Donald Trump tried
to spring the killer on them from the next
room over, that they were actually impressed
with Trump. They said that Trump was comforting,
that Trump was responding well to their grief,
which is something we have never seen Donald
Trump do or be in the face of tragedies. Usually
Donald Trump is the opposite of empathetic
and comforting. Uh, remember going to Puerto
Rico after the hurricane and shooting paper
towels like basketballs as if it's some kind
of game. The entire spectacle is completely
cruel and ill considered. And then to add
to this, apparently at some point, either
before or after their meeting with Trump,
uh, the, uh, Robert O'Brien, the U S national
security advisor told the family that an [inaudible]
coulis is never going back to the United Kingdom
to face justice.
On top of all of this, this is the Jerry Springer
ization of the presidency with the exception
that Jerry Springer actually showed some compassion
and empathy for the people on his program.
A headline that you have to really look at
closely to realize that it's not satirical
news, but it is the reality of the world in
Trump 2019, the era in which we now find ourselves